very vocal about saying Democrats who
complain about situation they're in only
have themselves to blame I
yeah in a way I mean you know and the
Nazis but I mean in a way you know you
know there's this other bad stuff it's
happening but I just remember in 2008
when we people were working hard you
know people were they were phonebank and
they were going to swing states to stop
John McCain right
I mean 2012 people work their butts off
to stop Mitt Romney who I would give a
lap dance to if he would come back to be
President policies it's a chance I would
take anybody but we worked our butts off
on these you know can't stop these guys
he's got a terrible and then when it was
Trump people said this is the worst guy
ever but we didn't work like it was
mm-hmm
we said oh we've got it in the bag and
it's just like my kids and they play
we're gonna play soccer
oh this team is trash we're gonna kill
this team Cheers
you know after was coming back home
because if you don't work hard you don't
win and so that's the thing my thing is
listen this is all terrible it's all bad
but in a democracy you can't sit here
and imagine that Bob Muller is a tooth
fairy that's gonna bring you the country
that you want tomorrow morning cuz
everybody oh my God he's gonna please
let him get impeached listen you know
even when they get impeached Clinton got
impeach and you serve his full term
impeachments not the thing it's removal
which has never happened so you've got
to stop with the to your cheerful
wishing for the bottom of the ninth home
run that I don't know it's it's it's the
hard work it's knocking on doors it's
support in the moveon.org xand the color
change doors and all those different
groups it's it's it's it's it's it's
doing the bone banks it's donating the
money it's figuring out where it's
called democracy and when we were in
that Barack Obama bubble bath for eight
years and we were so happy and then when
we got up we were wet and wrinkly and we
weren't ready to fight and we
be so now I can get back to work I've
never heard anyone say when we were in
that Barack Obama bubble back i sir was
not Barack Obama not yet not yet happen
Oh sounds like something you get if you
pledge enough money
you